this program is being presented to you
by the hereas international winter
school on gravity and light
okay so this is the lecture about
detecting gravitational waves
i'm going to try to address some of the
issues of principle that people always
ask me someone asked me during the break
and but but i'm
uh often asked questions like
if you know gravitational waves are a
distortion of space
uh uh and all of space is distorted and
the light is distorted and so on how can
how can you detect gravitational waves
with light and
all of that so i want to put all of
those things to rest and
and and and get you to the point where
you have a clear physical understanding
of what's going on
with the detection of gravitational
waves but then i also want to talk about
the the the kinds of
different ways that there are to detect
gravitational waves is not just
interferometers
and uh and then i want to talk about
some of the technologies involved
um and also uh if we have time a bit
about the space technologies but
this is not primarily about technology
this is primarily about
um the whole enterprise of detecting
gravitational waves and
and how it fits into physics so
this is to remind you of things that i
was showing you in the last
uh lecture this is the polarization
diagram drawn in a slightly different
way but you have the two
orthogonal polar polarizations the where
the
uh stretching is along the x y axis and
here where it's tilted
to 45 by where it's rotated by 45
degrees
and then the tidal representation the um
this is all to do with general
relativity if
if general relativity isn't correct if
there's some additional effects you
might have other polarizations
but we know that general relativity is
is predominantly correct to the one
percent level from
in terms of its predictions of
gravitational waves from the from the
binary pulsar kinds of observations and
therefore
um uh it's a good description
it's a good basis for providing a
description of detection of
gravitational waves if there are small
changes at the one percent level then
we'll learn things but it won't affect
whether we're actually detecting the
waves or not um
so the interferometer again is sitting
here
uh with the with the distortion and and
the light comes in here the
the interference pattern comes out there
and if you arrange it so there's
nothing this is a dark port coming out
when there's no gravitational wave then
when you get light
then that gives you the gravitational
wave
that's how that this diagram of the
interferometer
explains why we we really look for
to interferometers as a natural way of
detecting gravitational waves
but that wasn't the first way that
people tried to detect gravitational
waves the first attempt
was with um the the bar detectors
and this is a picture of joseph weber
the pioneer of the field with his first
bar detector at the university of
maryland in the united states
weber uh actually did consider
interferometry
um but this picture was taken probably
around 1965
and when was the first continuous wave
laser
uh probably later than that or or around
the same time
so 1961 was the first continuous wave
laser maybe yeah
so the the technology for laser
interferometry
uh for detection of gravitational waves
simply wasn't there and and weber
considered it and rejected it
and did what he could do at the time now
a bar detector
operates um mainly at its resonant
frequency it's a
it's a metal cylinder um aluminum or
steel
and um a gravitational wave comes in
from the side
and you want to think about the the
interference that that polarization
pattern
as the gravitational wave comes in from
the side the stretching in the x
direction
stretches the bar and then after the
gravitational wave is passed through
the bar has been stretched a little and
it oscillates and
you pick up that oscillation and he's
instrumented it with strain gauges at
the point where the strain is maximum
namely the center of the bar and
those strain gauges are supposed to tell
you about the excitation of the
fundamental normal mode of oscillation
of the bar
and so it's that resonant mode and for a
steel or
aluminium bar uh about a meter long or
something that the
typical frequencies are around the
kilohertz that's the
that would be the most sensitive
frequency for detecting gravitational
wave
there's an inherent limitation in this
which weber was well aware of but
uh um uh this was
after all just the first attempt uh
which is that if you
want to want to take advantage of the
title effect if you want to make
bigger is better if you want to make it
bigger then
it becomes impractical first the the
longest bar that's ever been made is
about three meters
for for gravitational wave detection um
but the
larger you make it the lower the
resonant frequency goes because it's a
acoustic oscillation of the bar
and so um uh if you make it if you want
to make a kill if you imagine making a
kilometer long
piece of aluminum if you could possibly
imagine uh
doing that it would have much too lower
frequency
uh so it's you can't take advantage of
the tidal effect of gravitational waves
um so there's an inherent limit on
sensitivity
the bars were pushed to
around 10 minus 19 by cooling them down
to very close to absolute zero liquid
helium temperature
um and still that wasn't good enough for
any detections and so bars are not being
operated now
um anymore uh there are there have been
a few projects to
more imaginative ways of doing bar
detectors but it's an inherently limited
technology there was a controversy over
weber which i'll just mention briefly
which was in in the late 1960s he
believed he was seeing gravitational
waves
and he published that he had two of
these bars one in
maryland and one in chicago and he
believed that they were being excited in
coincidence with one another
and um uh he published it and
the it looked good and then he also
showed that the codes that the
that the as the earth turned on its axis
he was getting more coincidences when
the one when the
bar was was broadside onto the center of
our galaxy
uh and therefore it was probably that
his excitations were coming from the
center of the galaxy which seemed
you know even more convincing um
uh but uh but but his sensitivity was
low and nobody could understand how
there could be so many events with such
high uh amplitude coming from the center
of the galaxy we
the galaxy would actually be losing a
lot of mass if that happened over
millions of years
um so um
there was skepticism as well and then
and then it turned out that his data
analysis was a bit suspect
uh he wasn't doing it with digitally he
was he was looking with his eye
at two different chart recordings and
you can fool yourself
with uh with that kind of procedure you
can
find things that are that you want to
find even if you
tell yourself you're being honest
and so um the only way to test it was to
build other bar detectors
and most of the groups that are now in
the interferometry business started out
building bar detectors to test weber
and um uh and all the bar detectors that
were built came up negative
nobody else saw the gravitational waves
at the same time weber continued to see
gravitational waves
uh so then there was as you can imagine
a terrible period in which this pioneer
this guy who is very clever
wound up being on the fringe he could
not admit
that he was mistaken he tried to invent
all sorts of new kinds of physics to
explain it
um and he he died eventually
a you know a a rather broken
uh very sad individual um
so it's a sad episode and it also led to
tremendous caution in the field so
ligo now sets a very high standard
for for the first detection of
confidence for the first detection
because we don't want to be in that
situation we don't want to fool
ourselves we don't want to be
even have people in the community asking
us
are we fooling ourselves we don't want
any of that so
so weber's left a legacy even though it
was in the 1960s
that it's still affecting the field
today
um so those are the bar detectors but uh
most effective detectors of
gravitational waves now are are beam
detectors they're
they use light the interaction of light
and gravitational waves and we call them
beam detectors a beam of light
with a gravitational wave field and so i
want to talk about this in general
what what the what the uh
interaction between light and
gravitational waves is now
in a local inertial frame if i'm uh
uh uh you know in a frame where i can
put down
a minkowski metric and just and i'm
freely falling
and i treat the gravitational wave as a
small perturbation on that minkowski
metric i have linearized gravitational
waves and we've you've studied those you
know what they
they look like they travel at the speed
of light through this local inertial
frame
so they're always locally going at the
speed of light
um but globally the gravitational waves
distort this geometry of space time
and that can affect the travel time
between one place and another
um that is taken by the gravitational
waves and so beam detectors basically
operate on the principle of trying to
measure
travel time of light through a
gravitational wave field
um so here's a simple experiment to
imagine um
people have imagined this uh from very
early on send
a beam of light from a freely following
source your laser or whatever it is and
and by freely falling i mean really out
in outer space with nothing around
that's not that's what we'll do with
lisa it's not what we do on the ground
because we're not freely falling on the
ground so you have to
go to you know next order and ask
yourself does that have any effect but
but the but the principle of the
detection is easiest to see
if you're in uh in empty space you're
freely falling
and you have a light source and it goes
out and reflects off some mirror
and comes directly back to you so a
return trip
how much proper time on your clock you
have you're freely falling you have a
clock
a nice special relativity clock how much
proper time on that clock
is elapsed for that return trip okay
and if you monitor that and the
gravitational waves are going through
you will find that that time changes
and that's a measure of gravitational
waves and that's the principle of
measurement
that's used in interferometers and other
kinds of beam detectors
uh measuring the variations in that
return time
um and it's a
it's a it's an it's something that's
independent of
coordinate systems or gauges or anything
else you have a physical object here
which is sending out light
your physical object out there which is
reflecting it
both in free fall and you have a clock
that's measuring proper time locally
there's nothing
to do with coordinates in this
experiment and uh
so you can calculate in any coordinate
system you want in general relativity
what the return time is going to be it's
going to be the same uh because
it's um it's a it's a measurable it's a
coordinate independent measurable
um so uh um
now there's a there's a very important
formula
um which is uh called the three term
relation
very prosaic name for for uh what is the
fundamental formula for this whole
business
um if you have a gravitational wave so
let's suppose the beam is
the beam of light is going out that way
and my mirror is down there somewhere
and
that's coming back to me the
gravitational wave is coming along
at an angle theta to that to that beam
okay so
uh it's not a perfectly symmetrical
geometry so there's an angle here
which is which is the the direction
between the direction of
travel of the of the gravitational wave
and the direction of travel
of the light that's what theta is and
the answer for this return time is
i'm going to monitor the return time as
the rate of change of the return time so
the
t here is the proper time on my local
clock and i'm just going to say
what's the variation what's the time
variation of this
uh of the return time um and of course
if there's no gravitational waves so you
see a gravitational wave amplitude h
plus h plus is one of the polarization
states i'm taking
the polarization ellipse so that um
uh the uh when
there's a common there's a common axis
which is the when the gravitational wave
is going through and
and the intersection with the uh with
the light direction
i'm going to take the x-axis in that in
that
common plane and that's the orientation
that i take for my polarization so
that's the
other polarization component won't
contribute to the signal only there's
one polarization what does
so i'll call that h plus and you see
each of these things depend determine it
depends on h plus
if there's no gravitational wave if h
plus is zero you just get one
okay one means the light is coming back
always with the same return time so uh
there's no variation
um uh so you ignore the one and and
you're trying to measure these small
variations of order h
the remarkable thing is that um there's
only three
times in during during the during the
signal that are important
so this is the argument of h h is uh
um uh the the value of h
at at your location at the where you're
sending out the light
it's uh it's the uh um the wave field is
passing through
and so it's the value at a particular
time and
um the particular time
um is uh um
this is this is as a function of the
time you sent the light out not the time
you receive it so t
in here is the time when the light was
sent out no uh and then when it's coming
back is t return
so t is the emitted time so here's
here's the amplitude of gravitational
waves at the time
you're emitting it and there's a factor
here that depends upon
a sine of theta um
here is a uh
an argument t plus 2l that's when the
light has come back
now of course return time is affected by
age so
there's a small the return time is maybe
t plus 2l plus a little bit of h but
this is already an argument
to h so that's a second order change so
you don't have to worry about
that as an argument of h so this is the
return time this is when the light has
come back
so these two terms are the gravitational
wave at
you um when you set the light out when
you receive it back
and this this one however is is is
some intermediate time it's um uh
uh uh l times
l is the is the path length the light
the distance out to the to the
to your reflector and this is um one
minus sine theta
uh that comes in and we'll we'll talk a
little bit about that but that's an
intermediate time
so there's three terms in here that's
why it's called three termination
that that effect it's not like it's a
continuous time
um uh h it's just three times
um three different points in the
evolution of that waveform
that affect the return time
let's talk about the geometry so suppose
that
suppose that that the angle
is such that um
that that uh sine theta is equal to one
the angle is 90 degrees
um um
uh i should have drawn the i should have
drawn what the
uh what the uh
geometry is um maybe i should
um oh
okay
so i should have had this diagram here
you have your
you have your your laser here sending
out light
and you have a mirror here that's
reflecting it back and this is a
distance l
and then you have a gravitational wave
coming through
uh with with uh wave fronts
it's a plane wave that's going through
like that the angle theta
is the is the angle between the wave
fronts
and the um and the path of the light
so um you can think of
uh of of this as the angle theta
um so if theta is zero
uh if theta is is is pi over two then
you have a wave coming along here so
theta equals pi over two
is the wave the gravitational wave
is is parallel to the light it's going
along the same direction
as the light so that's that's when i
tilt over here
i make theta equal pi over 2. if you
look at what happens when theta is pi
over two sine theta
is equal to one the first term has a
factor of zero in front the second term
is a factor of two
h plus of t the third term has a factor
of two
and then here the one minus sine theta
that's
that's um uh uh
equal to one so so uh this is at uh
uh this is one minus one that's zero so
the l drops out and it's just a t
and that's the same argument as here so
this term and that term cancel out and
that one is zero
and you get no no effect so when a
gravitational wave is going along here
you don't get any disturbance on the
light at all
and that's because they keep phase with
each other
the action is all transverse and so
there's no disturbance to the light
so that just to normalize the angle
theta for you
the transverse thing here is where theta
equals
zero coming in broadside that's where
you would expect the maximum effect
and um uh if so theta equals zero you
the first term is is fully there the
second term is
uh fully there and the third term is
absent
uh completely so you have just the the
the
sending out time and then and then the
return time and it doesn't even
it isn't even affected by by when the
light is bouncing off the mirror that's
that's interesting it's just the
gravitational wave amplitudes
at the emission and return uh
time that that matter for the for the
signal so that's with theta equals zero
but if you have an intermediate theta
then this term
the the mirror term does uh have some
effect
all right so that's the three term
relation and and it's purely it's a it's
a measurable
and it comes out of gra it comes out of
general relativity any coordinate system
and it just assumes that the
gravitational wave is just a property of
the gravitational wave traveling at the
speed of light
um has nothing to do with the wavelength
of the light that you're using
so sometimes people say well is the
wavelength stretched you know you're
doing a
a an interferometry experiment the
wavelength is important is the
wavelength light affected
that's irrelevant that it's all to do
with the return time
of the light going back and forth um
so let's see how that let's see how that
works
uh this is a busy slide i hope yeah
i hope you can see it i want to talk
about different kinds of beam detectors
uh first is spacecraft tracking
thermometers
from the 1960s people at
at nasa understood that they're sending
spacecraft out through the solar system
and that if you sent signals out to the
spacecraft and got them back
and monitored the return time you were
doing this three-term
experiment you were doing exactly that
experiment
and you might be able to detect
gravitational waves like that in fact
that three-term
formula was derived by people working at
the jet propulsion laboratory
in california for for nasa that was the
first time anybody had ever
fully explored the quantitative
interaction of gravitational waves with
light because that's what they wanted
to do is that is that experiment so they
first began to do that with spacecraft
in the late 60s early 70s the pioneer um
were were involved but also um many of
the later
missions to the outer planets uh also
had it carried experiments
the idea was uh send radio waves out
um and and get them transponded a
transponder is a
is a radio receiver transmitter which
which tries to send signals back tries
to send exactly
a signal answering signal when it
receives one it tries to answer with a
minimum delay or with a known delay
so you can measure the time of travel
and do that experiment um so that's what
the transponders were doing
the sensitivity of this kind of
experiment is limited by the fact that
you're not in vacuum
you're in it there's an interplanetary
plasma that affects the travel time of
radio waves
and so the time return time that you get
isn't just a function of the
gravitational waves
so you have noise from the plasma and
also you have to measure
what i didn't talk about of course is
you have to measure that return time so
you have to have a very good
clock and so you have atomic clocks um
at the radio telescopes
on the earth in the in the deep space
network uh nasa's
instrument of the deep space network
with extremely good uh atomic clocks
those clocks some of the best in the in
the world are stable at some level like
10 minus 16 or 10 minus 17 well
probably 10 minus 16. um and that is the
limit
um you you wouldn't be able to detect
variations at less than parts and 10 of
the 16
if you have a clock that isn't reliable
with those um
accuracies and so the typical values of
h that you can
get from from all this around 10 to the
minus 16. the frequency band is one over
the time scale so basically you're
looking for
effects that happen over the time scale
and of transplanting and so on
so it's millihertz
uh and these experiments have been run
many times
the galileo mission uh was the most
recent one and and
i think and and they um uh come out with
uh numbers like that but they have never
detected gravitational waves
um but that's that's the uh the classic
beam detector of the kind that i just
was talking about
there's another variation on this which
is called pulsar timing which
i've talked about where you get po where
you get pulses of radio waves from
distant pulsars
the radio waves travel through the
gravitational wave field arrive at your
location
the trouble is we're not sending them
back we don't send a signal out to the
pulsar which is
which is after all thousands of light
years away and would be a very difficult
experience experiment to do so we're
just relying on this on the pulsar
giving us these regular signals
so it's not a two-way it's not an up and
back it's just a one-way thing
but you can do the one-way calculation
and it's you come out with numbers that
are
similar of course formulas that are
um uh there the
and what you get is that h matters both
at the earth
and at the pulsar the the it's affected
by whatever gravitational wave field was
passing the pulsar
a thousand years ago when that radio
pulse was emitted
and what gravitational wave field is
passing the earth right now
but the pulsars are all over the sky and
the gravitational wave field
at the pulsar and at this pulsar and
that pulsar are not correlated with one
another so that's basically a noise
so you average over all the pulsars so
you don't pick up any information about
the gravitational waves
at the pulsars you you only get the
correlated
effect which is the gravitational wave
at the at the earth
at the time all these pulses are
arriving at the same time
so that's what you're well that's what
you're measuring is the gravitational
wave
um uh uh at the earth
the sensitivity of these experiments is
limited by clocks on earth again your
timing
um and um and also it's it's limited by
intrinsic pulsar
irregularities we the pulses are
uh some pulsars are quite noisy and we
don't want to use those but there are
some pulsars called millisecond pulsars
which are extremely clean where the
pulse is just coming out
with great regularity the individual
pulses can still
vary quite a lot but when you average
over about a year
with these millisecond pulsars and take
out a few systematic trends that are
the radio astronomers observe then you
get
a very clean signal from several pulsars
there's probably about 20 pulsars around
the sky that could be used for
for timing um they're so clean
that even with the best atomic clocks we
cannot detect
variations irregularities in their
pulses
so we don't know if they're better
clocks
but over time scales of about a year it
looks like the pulsars may be better
clocks than the
best clocks we can build at the moment
so so the limits on pulsar timing are
set by
clocks and the intrinsic
pulsar irregularities are either on the
same time scale as the clock
irregularities or maybe even better
so as our clocks improve pulsar timing
will improve
um but it means that the pulsar timing
is still limited around 10 by 16. but i
showed you earlier
that the that albertos suzanna's
predictions for gravitational wave
backgrounds for pulsar timing
are in that range around 10 minus 16.
those are strong
background chaotic stochastic signals
um so um uh uh
so pulsar timing unlike the signals
looking for spacecraft tracking pulsar
timing
has a chance of detecting even with the
clocks that exist today
the frequency band is not set by
transmission time which is the
thousands of years it's set by the
averaging time to get to very stable
pulsar
um uh arrival times and that's a
averaging time of about a year
so that means that what we're observing
with pulsar time is about
one to ten nanohertz it's it's below
frequency of leesa band it's a totally
different frequency band than anything
else
accessible to us and the sources are
these supermassive black holes
uh and they're binaries and so on
so if i then go to to the next one um
imagine building a one arm detector
a one arm detector with a clock it's
just like spacecraft tracking it's the
same thing
you you send light up and down it's the
thought experiment i just did and i have
a very good clock
and i do that why don't i build a
gravitational wave detector like that
why don't i put one of those on the
ground or in space why go to the
extra effort of building two arms for an
interferometer because it's
all very expensive big vacuum system and
lots of civil engineering
and so on well the so so the one arm is
is the
would be the would be the instrument of
choice if you could do it
but again we come down to the clocks the
one arm detector is limited by the
clocks both of these things are are
clock limited
and right now it's 10 minus 16. the
people who build
atomic clocks have great ambitions
they're hoping to to put
to to be able to construct clocks that
get to 10 minus 18
um in the very near future 10 minus 19
maybe 10 minus 20. so i put 10
minus 20 here but 10 minus 20 isn't good
enough
to get to the kinds of sensitivity
levels that we need
for ground-based detection in the
kilohertz band and so that's why we
don't have just one arm detectors with
good clocks we just don't have clocks
good enough
as soon as the clocks get good enough we
may you know
uh do that but at the moment we need
interferometers and i'll come back to
interferometers
but we we in principle you could use a
one arm detector with a clock
if you had one the frequency band would
be determined by the arm length
the time up and up and down um uh
would be a sort of sampling time and um
and also then by the clock stability
time scale so
how how much the clocks um
variation i have a question does that
involve
putting clocks very sensitive clocks on
spacecrafts that
go somewhere far away uh well i
imagine you know for one arm detector i
imagine you could build it on the ground
and you just have a clock um at the
place where you're sending the laser out
but in space then you would have a you
would have to
face the additional complication of
putting a really good atomic clock in
space
if we have any high precision clock
outside like
maybe there is something on voyager or
pioneer or something like that
yeah that's right but those cloud the
but but the clocks you can put in space
are always one or two generations behind
the ones you can build on the ground
um the um
uh but what is but but the next
paragraph is
relevant to that because there's a lot
of discussion right now of a
atom interferometry um
for gravitational wave detector
detection now
you know that that atoms and particles
are at a quantum level are waves there's
a the
the the wave particle duality and so you
you can imagine constructing an
interferometer
in which the medium is that's being
interfered is not
light but is is atoms and people have
done this um to demonstrate
uh the wave nature of matter um and you
could imagine
using that to detect gravitational waves
uh in the same way
uh it wouldn't you'd have a different
three-term relation all that would be
different but
but in principle you could detect
gravitational waves that way um
that's way in the future nobody knows
yet any practical way of doing that
but the people who do adam
interferometry are proposing to build a
space
a one-armed space detector
in which basically atom interferometer
takes the
takes the role of the clocks and you
have uh
clouds of uh atoms that are ejected at
both ends
and so you don't have a a return time
you have you have a
uh the transition that
is being used for the for the clock is
is uh uh uh the same and you
set up you pass a beam of light through
the atoms
uh at one end and that imprints a
certain state a certain quantum state
there there's a it's all to do with
entangled states
and then when you get to the other end
you resolve the entanglement
and hopefully that gives you a higher
accuracy
than atomic clocks so you're not
measuring time with an atomic clock
you're just measuring a phase
or or time transmission differential so
it's not as demanding as having a full
atomic clock but but it's um
something you might be able to do with
out of interferometry so this is being
i'm a member of a committee for
esa we've we've talked about this as a
future technology some of the people who
do this
are members of the committee it doesn't
look like it's a technology that we can
use on the time scale of lisa
but it is it is something that might
come along for a next generation lisa
um and so so keep your eye on adam
interferometry
for gravitational wave detection it's a
kind of hybrid between
it's a beam detector but instead of
having clocks that's using atom
interferometry and entanglement
would be very sexy so
that's those are all the things that i
wanted to get out of the way before i
came to the one that is the most
effective one
which is the laser interferometer um i
wanted to explain to you why we don't do
these other things
all of which might seem a bit easier but
we do pulse our timing and it's a
different frequency range
but um why are we doing the laser
interferometers with their two arms
instead of one
and all the um uh uh stuff that's going
on
the reason is you can think of it
physically as the second arm
is is is basically the time reference
for the fir
for the other arm um you can't build a
clock
that's accurate to that level but if you
have two cavities
uh uh that are both uh being uh
stabilized then
you're beating one cavity against the
other and so
your your um uh your accuracy
uh 10-21 or or or whatever
is now how how stable can you make those
cavities
that that you can get a time reference
or a phase reference out of each of
those cavities
the the difference be it's not exactly
having one of them as a clock and one of
them is a gravitational wave detector
because they're both cavities they're
both affected by the gravitational wave
as it comes through
and so what you pick up is the
difference between
what happens in one arm and what happens
in the other so it's a different uh
the three term relation has to be put
together in two perpendicular ways to
get
to get the uh response to the
interferometer out
okay um but that but but you can
you can do all that uh you have a
different angle theta and and all that
but
but uh it's fairly straightforward to
work out what the response of an
interferometer is
the sensitivity is then limited by how
well you can build the cavities and
there's the environment
environmental noise seismic noise and so
on there's laser noise
there's the photon shot noise and i'll
be talking about some of these later on
thermal effects in the mirrors mirror
quality the
the shape of the mirrors all these
things affect how well you can make your
cavities
and how how good you can make your uh
detector but
but we do believe we can get detectives
10 minus 22
in the next few months and 10 minus 23
or 10
minus 24 when we um push the
technologies even further
the frequency band is determined by the
arm length basically
um but but it's a it's a slightly
it's determined but it's not equal to
the arm length or one over the arm
length
um because we use we use in in these
cavities we use multiple reflections of
light and so we build up a signal in a
cavity
that's much um that stays in the cavity
much longer than a single light crossing
time of the cavity so
so the cavities may have may have let's
say
a um a a natural frequency range around
uh around 100 kilohertz or something
like that
but actually we're measuring one
kilohertz gravitational waves or 100
hertz gravitational waves
by by keeping the light in the cavities
for much longer periods of time um
so but it's basically the alarm length
and when we go into space
we have much longer arms we have
millions of kilometers instead of a few
kilometers
and so then then we go to the um
millihertz band from from the sp
from the ground base bend um there is
one thing i wanted to do
uh sorry i should have done before so
let me go back
to to this diagram
to the three term relation um
i want to also um
look at the short arm so i've made no
assumption about how long
l is um uh in relation to let's say
the wavelength of gravitational waves so
the wavelength of gravitational waves
comes into this
because if l is short compared to the
frequency wavelength of the
gravitational waves or or
then 2l is a short time compared to the
period of the gravitational wave
and you can do a taylor expansion of h
dot of h
and and just keep first order in l okay
so in the short
in the small detector limit where the
way the arm length is small compared to
the the wavelength i can i can simplify
this by doing a taylor expansion
and what
what happens when i do that if you go
through all of it you get something
where um uh i just get the first order
terms in l
i mean we've we've effectively done that
i mean if i set l equals zero
uh then all these terms are bound to
cancel out if i have a
no armed if i have a no arm detector l
equals zero i'm not going to get any
uh signal so um so to first order in l
everything that comes out here will be
proportional to l and so the signal
that i'm measuring is proportional to l
and you can understand that in physical
terms
for a short detector compared to the
wavelength of gravitational wave
you're in the diagram where the where
the the title effect
is is uh uh coherent across your whole
detector
and so you're just stretching it out in
proper distance and then compressing it
in proper distance
everything is depending about just on l
uh and that's
a simple picture and that's what we have
on the ground that picture fails
if l is much bigger or comparable
to the wavelength of the gravitational
wave because then the gravitational
waves can be coming through this
picture in the way i've drawn them with
short wavelengths compared to l
and so the the light is going through a
fluctuating wave field
and you're getting cancellations you're
getting some effect and it cancels out
and so on
and all of that is in this formula you
can rely on this formula
um but it means that it's not just a
simple
uh coherent expansion and contraction uh
and with lisa we're in that regime
lisa's arm lengths of millions of
kilometers are longer
than some of the wavelengths are
comparable to some of the wavelengths
and that has some effect on lisa's
sensitivity and
and so on at the higher frequency end so
that's just something i wanted to point
out that there's
um this thing gets simpler if i if i go
to the short way
the short arm limit and that is
appropriate for
uh ground-based detection okay
um uh so so i did the all the beam
detectors now
whoops um now i want to do
um one other before i come back to the
information i want to talk about one
other way in which people are talking
about detecting gravitational waves
which is the cosmic microwave background
and we had last year this excitement
from the bicep 2
experiment that they thought they had
seen the signal of gravitational waves
what's going on there it's even though
cosmic microwaves are microwaves
uh it's not a beam detector we're not
seeing
time variations in the in the
transmission of cosmic microwaves
uh to our detectors what we're seeing is
the imprint of gravitational waves
on the polarization waves so
a photon scattering off of the charges
that are moving
then that alters the polarization
pattern if the charge is stationary
you'll have a random polarization
but if if if the plasma is moving this
way
you get preferential polarization one in
in the transverse direction
so um so a gravitational wave
uh sort of coherently stretching out the
plasma
at the just at the time when the
universe is becoming transparent will
leave an imprint
of uh in the polarization signal of
of its existence and that's what people
are looking for the
the and that's a scattering so um
it's a bit more like a bar experiment
because the bar
you have a mechanical system being
distorted in some way by the
gravitational wave
and then you then you try to figure out
what's happening
the microwaves are carrying us the
signal of what's happening but it's not
a beam detector
um uh the density perturbations
were around one part and 10 of the six
at the time
that's all these nice little
fluctuations in in them these wonderful
diagrams that come out of cmb
observations so the gravitational wave
perturbations
uh might have had a similar amplitude
and
the bicep two is is um an experiment
that would
would allow the detection of
gravitational waves at that sort of
amplitude
um if they were there um
and um and so that's the sensitivity and
this and the cmb
um the sky resolution of the cmb all
these little fluctuation
elements that you can resolve uh that
determines the wavelengths of the
gravitational waves because
what you're seeing is in each one of
these cells which is a
you know the angular resolution of these
cmb experiments
you have to have a coherent
gravitational wave signal so you're
seeing the gravitational wave
that had the wavelength at the time that
fills up that
angular region on the sky today okay um
so um uh it's
uh maybe a thousandth of the hubble
horizon at the time
at that time uh um that's what the
wavelengths of the gravitational waves
are
that you are selected by this method uh
and as you know i i'm sure the bicep
team have had to agree that that the
measurements from the planck satellite
um indicate that they didn't have the
sensitivity to
see gravitational waves because they
reflect their background fluctuation
foreground fluctuations caused by by
intermediate uh ionization and so on on
the plasma
uh on on the on this cosmic microwave
background so you're not going to see
those in the in the bicep 2 data
but you may be able to peer through that
you may the way to get through that is
that the
foregrounds have a different have a
frequency dependence that is different
from the
from the from the cosmic microwave
background so if you can measure over a
big frequency range
bicep two only measure one frequency if
you can measure
over at several cosmic microwave
background frequencies you can subtract
the foreground signal and try to get
below it and that's what people are
doing now and so if
if the gravitational waves are at this
10-6 level then in another
uh year or so we may we may really have
a measurement
um but there are a lot of people who um
a lot of theorists who predict the
gravitational wave signal is actually
zero
so um uh any any you know uh
we may well we might get upper limits
and and it's hard to predict when we're
going to get to that
level but i wanted to talk about that
because it's another way of detecting
gravitational waves
that's quite different from the things
that we've been talking about
but now in the last uh part of this
lecture i want to talk about
interferometers
um and i think they're wonderful
instruments because they involve
practically every branch of physics
um you if you love thermodynamics then
you're going to
find a place in a team that builds
gravitational wave detect is controlling
the thermal effects in in mirrors if you
uh
are a materials person then we really
need you to help us
with things like suspending suspending
the
the mirrors and uh constructing the
mirrors
um uh themselves um ev
you know optics uh uh obviously quantum
optics obviously everything goes
practically every every branch of
physics comes in somehow
um the principle of the of the
interferometer
um uh uh i'll come back to
uh sorry uh uh uh there are some very
interesting things
and some myths about inferometers i want
to explode a bit later
but but let's just talk about um uh
the the limitations so environmental
disturbances are a big limitation the
two primary sources are environmental
and laser short
shot noise so environmental disturbances
means
noise from the ground um uh
and the way we get rid of that is our
pendulum suspensions
so we hang the mirrors from
maybe a mirror a meter or more of
a suspension and you know with a
pendulum
that it's a it's a mechanical filter
that if you wiggle
the top of a pendulum at a very high
frequency compared to the pendulum
frequency
then the pendulum hardly moves at all if
you
move the top of the pendulum at a low
frequency compared to the pendulum
frequency then the pendulum just follows
along and with your motion
so it's a it's a it's a low-pass
mechanical filter
and what we do in ligo uh and was
developed in geo is we have a three
stage suspension
three ganged pendulum so we have the
product of three
filter functions um uh so we have a very
steep falloff
of of seismic noise but but basically
the turning point is around the hertz
and so
we have a lot of noise in the system at
a hertz and then it falls off very fast
and by the time we get to observing
frequencies around 10 hertz we hope
um then it should be low enough for us
to be able to to
to uh to observe so so
uh the the lower limit on our frequency
uh band is set by the pendulum
at the upper end of frequencies very few
noise sources come in the the
the it's it's actually easy to build a
relatively easy build an interferometer
that is isolated and
and and and so on and so at the upper
upper end um we're limited by the amount
of laser light that we can put in
because laser light is quantized and you
have photons and the photons arrive
at the beam splitter in a random way and
that causes
tiny fluctuations in the intensity of
the light that comes out
even in a in a perfectly stable
interference pattern you'll have these
little fluctuations
and so um they have to be at a that sets
a noise limit that's the noise in our
interferometer that's called laser shot
noise
uh that dominates at the high
frequencies and i'll show you some
some some uh examples of that um
but if you understand these two kinds of
noise you understand the sensitivity of
gravitational wave detectors pretty much
um and we have ways of attacking
uh uh attacking this we we have uh
uh in virgo they they're even doing a
better job at the
for the environmental disturbances they
have they have they have six stage
pendulum
suspensions laser shot noise you can
affect by squeezing
you can put the laser light into a
quantum state so the fluctuations in
intensity
at the exit port where you're measuring
it are actually
lower um you you make you
effectively make two beams correlated so
that photons arrive back in a correlated
fashion um that's called squeezed light
and we're doing that we
did that in geo and i'll show you some
results of that and
that's being put into the big
interferometers in a second stage so
um we'll get below the standard shot
noise limit but it'll still be laser
noise a photon noise that affects it
all right now here's a quick
introduction to how to build
interferometer how it works
this is a standard what we call a
michelson interferometer
laser beam splitter mirror up there
mirror down mirror over there and photo
detector light comes out of the laser
reflects it gets split here into two
beams
reflects back the two beams come back
there's an interference pattern on the
on the beam splitter
some of the light is reflected back in
this direction and
this is the constructive interference
pattern and this is the destructive
interference pattern goes out here
now normally we want to run so that this
is zero normally we don't want anything
coming out here so that when we get a
signal
we go up from zero to something that's a
good signal noise change
um and then we're only limited by the
noise in our photo detector
but that has the remarkable and somewhat
disturbing
result that all the light is going back
in this direction
right if nothing's come out here then
it's all going back here
and uh and it hits the wall and burns a
hole in your wall
and um is is is lost so
ron drever back in the 1980s had the
wonderful idea
of um catching catching oh no sorry i'm
getting ahead of myself
the next thing is first of all um
uh why just put the light just up and
down once why not put
another mirror here and then catch the
light
and what i've shown is it bounces up and
down just once
which is actually what happens in geo
but
but in uh it's slightly different than
the other ones but but this is what i
was telling you about
is basically you store the light in the
arms for longer than the light travel
time up and down the arm here you
you're doubling the light travel time
with one bounce but you can imagine lots
of bounces and in fact
in in a detector that was a prototype
for geo that was built in
in uh garking near munich um
they had they had about 40 reflections
on a big mirror they had different spots
on this
on this on this interior mirror and they
had 40 independent bounces before the
light came back out it was really
elaborate
um uh but it was also quite difficult to
control and we don't do things that way
anymore there are more sophisticated
ways of doing it but nevertheless the
principle is the same you store the
light here
the what that does is effectively
increase the arm length remember we're
in the short arm
uh regime and so the gravitational wave
is coherent
uh over this whole detector if you store
the light in the in the arm it just
keeps acting in the same way it just
keeps stretching it out and stretching
it and stretching out
so as long as you store it for less than
about a quarter of the period of the
gravitational wave
you get a coherent effect on all those
bounces and and the signal just builds
up
and so that's the idea of of storing
light and that's a big advance
that that really improves the
sensitivity it effectively makes
the arm length much longer than you
could build in practice
i'll come back to that as an important
aspect
but then what i said ron dreever at
glasgow had this wonderful idea of power
recycling
why not catch the light that's coming
back here this is the light that's
wasted
catch it and send it back in and reuse
it
and so if you just catch it in such a
way that
that you make sure it comes back in with
the same phase
see the gravitational wave isn't
imprinted there because it's the sum
um uh here's the difference and that's
where you see the gravitational wave but
there's no gravitational wave signal
in here and so uh you just catch it and
you make sure it's in phase with the new
light that's coming in
and you recycle it it's wonderful it's
all very environmental today
uh it's recycling and um
so it's power recycling and and that's
what uh ron
in uh ron uh uh proposed also was
proposed by
um uh a shilling uh uh in
in in munich at this at roughly the same
time the two of them
had the this idea independently they
were both working on the
things they realized that they were
wasting a lot of light why not grab it
and bring it back in
now if you have perfect mirrors then you
wind up with a laser bomb
because because nothing ever comes out
there's no gravitational wave down here
allowing you so the light builds up
until you know um
you but that doesn't i'll come back to
you but that doesn't really happen
because you have losses at the mirrors
you have reflection
losses some scattering uh some
absorption and so on
but what happens is that the light up in
here
until it's limited by those reflections
and losses so the losses of
so this laser is supplying the losses at
the mirrors
all right so that if you can make your
mirrors really good and we have mirrors
with losses of 10 to the
one part and 10 of the six so that means
you can have a million times as much
power
inside the cavities as the laser power
coming in
and the laser power is just re just
replacing the losses
so this is a huge improvement in
sensitivity
a huge reduction in in shot noise sorry
no
why wouldn't you
um you mean remove these mirrors
this it to the other side of the one
and remove the the mirrors
which are within the laser construction
you mean remove these
in the little box there's probably some
mirrors inside
oh i see no you wouldn't do that because
because then you'd have a huge amount of
light going through the laser and it
would be it would distort all
the optics and so on you have to have a
really really sharp line here
and you want this laser to be very very
well controlled so you wouldn't do that
you wouldn't want all that light going
through the laser
it's much better to just just just
adjust the phase
with feedback systems so that they're in
phase it's pretty easy to do
i thought you were going to remove these
what what actually happens
is that this is a good design for for
geo
geo uh only only has one bounce but then
gets all of its sensitivity
through through this amazing light
recycling
in in um in ligo
and virgo there's a lot more um
reflections here which means that the
power is all stored in these arms
and there's the power recycling doesn't
actually come out to here
with such intensity as it does with geo
and that's a big problem for the
beam splitter the beam splitter in geo
has a huge
thermal load on it because it all the
recycled light is going through it
um it's a limitation on geo sensitivity
the ligo and virgo designs don't put so
much loading on the beam splitter and
that's a
an advantage but those are technical
things
okay so now what what um the
the next thing that i want to add in is
the final
recycling which also ron driver invented
um uh
no uh sorry that's not quite true it was
before andreas fryza it was someone in
glasgow who i'm
trying to remember um it wasn't dr was
it was um
a guy who unfortunately was killed in a
climbing accident and he's no longer
with us um
therefore i'm ashamed i can't pull his
name out but
uh the the idea of signal recycling was
first uh
proposed um in the late 1980s
um uh again in the glasgow group
and uh what this does is you put a
mirror here at the output port where the
fringes are now if there's no
gravitational wave this mirror doesn't
do anything
but if it's a gravitational wave you can
tune this mirror you can make it partly
reflecting and you can put it in a
particular place
to tune this whole cavity and basically
reflect the signal back and forth
and build up the signal in a particular
bandwidth so that
the more reflection you have the higher
the reflectivity the narrower
band you make you make this into a kind
of resonant detector with a narrow
bandwidth
um if you have only a partial
reflectivity you're shaping the signal
uh a little bit um and this is this has
been done and tested in in geo
it will be done um in the big detectors
as well
for for mainly for shaping the signal
but we can improve
if we put in the right kind of mirror we
can improve the sensitivity of
these big interferometers in particular
frequency bands if we want to
go after a particular signal um
so all of these are are tricks that
people have invented and that that's the
basically what
our interferometers um are doing
and um
uh the final step is as i've said we put
in cavities here in
in ligo and virgo you have a a
a whole um uh cavity here instead of
just a bunch of multiple reflections
so this mirror is is partly sir it's 99
silver to something and and so some of
the light comes back
out this one is totally reflecting and
you build up most of the power in the
arms is in these cavities and that's how
most of these detectors work now i want
to correct some misconceptions
um uh two things i've been saying to you
all along and you probably believe
are wrong and now you can understand why
they're wrong um
i might not have said this but you
probably
believe this we need we need freely
falling test masses for the mirrors and
that's why we're hanging them
so that they respond to the
gravitational wave as it comes along
that's actually not the reason we hang
them we we hang them
for the reason i talked about earlier
which is to isolate them from ground
vibration
uh we use the mechanical filtering the
reason
that i don't that they're free anyway
they would even if i
nailed them down those mirrors if i had
them on a rigid suspension attached to
the ground
they would still move with the
gravitational wave
and the reason for that is that the
earth is not rigid enough to stop the
moving
so you have this gravitational wave
which is a very weak thing i'm not
saying it's a big movement
but it happens on a time time scale of
milliseconds
the rigidity of the earth if you have a
station here in a station there that is
separated by
a couple of kilometers the rigidity of
the earth is dependent upon
pressure waves going through the earth
to counteract
whatever stretching is going on and the
and the
speed of seismic waves going through the
earth is rather slow
so when this station moves this station
doesn't get this
this the pull of it um uh until
much much later than than a few
milliseconds
and so so for purposes of gravitational
waves
these two stations would actually be
free anyway um
uh to move in the horizontal direction
um or to move in any direction
so the reason we suspend them is because
we want to isolate them from all the
vibrations that are coming through the
earth all that vibration and everything
else that's going on
would get in the way of the signal that
means we're only sensitive in this
direction because because then
that's where the isolation is affecting
going up and down the suspension will
just carry them up and down so we don't
detect gravitational waves in the
vertical direction we're only detecting
stretching in the horizontal direction
but it's all to do with the suspension
uh and vibrational isolations not to do
with the fact that we need them to be
freely falling bodies
they are freely falling bodies in this
time skill
region uh the second misconception which
i
certainly am guilty of having said to
you is you know bigger is better
we build our detectors kilometer size on
the earth
in order to get them to be very big um
and build up signal well i've already
i've already told you why that's wrong
which is the fact that we have these
this multiple reflections in here that
increase the length of the arm length so
so i could actually build uh geo 600
let's say a 600 meters
uh compared to three three kilometers it
it
i could build up the same signal the
same signal sensitivity in g0600 by just
having
that many more reflections okay and
doing my optics better
why we build the thing why why it's
better to have a bigger
detector than a geo 600 is that there
are other noise sources
and and particularly we have the
vibration noise that comes in through
the suspension
we have thermal vibrations in the
mirrors and so on and
the more times you bump into a mirror
the more times you pick that noise up
and so um we want mirrors to be far
apart
so we can store light in those arms but
we minimize
the uh the number of times the light is
in contact with the mirrors
and in in geo there and the the light
contacts the mirrors
four or five times more often and so we
have a background of noise
that is much harder to get rid of
than in the larger detectors and and if
we could build a 10 kilometer detector
like we
plan to do with einstein uh telescope
underground
then we would reduce that effect even
more so that's the reason for going long
arms
is to minimize the mechanical um
noise inputs when when you're contacting
the mirrors
okay so that was in order to get rid of
that
now i have only a couple more things to
do quantum noise for example
is um uh uh what i what i talked about
um um is this is an introduction to how
we do squeezing
uh here's the laser interferometer
the same diagram as you've seen this is
actually what geo looks like this is a
diagram of geo which is where we
introduced squeezing
so geo has just one reflection and it
doesn't have the interior mirrors and so
on so it's a folded arm
and all the light goes through the beam
splitter and and all the power is on the
power recycling mirror
and there is actually there is actually
a signal recycling mirror not shown in
this diagram because not relevant to
what i'm talking about
but basically this is a closed system
except it has one it's open to the rest
of the world only here
we we talk about the the signal coming
out in the
for in the interference pattern but
there's also stuff coming in
in particular there's the vacuum the the
electromagnetic vacuum
is coming in this way it's the only way
it can get into your detector
um and the electromagnetic vacuum at a
quantum level
is noisy it has the zero point
fluctuation of
all the quantum
modes of of your um electromagnetic
field
and so those zero point fluctuations get
into here
and that's you there's a way of
formulating the shot noise problem
the the the noise of photon arrival
times and so on that i was talking about
there's a way of formulating that
problem in quantum mechanics
entirely in terms of this noise as a
smooth classical field
with this noise imposed upon it which is
coming into your detector
so shot so to control this to
to do squeezed light so that's the
vacuum noise that's
i just said is is coming in um
well you put a mirror here you put a an
apparatus here you put a mirror here
and um uh you stop
um the the vacuum coming in in
in a raw way and you squeeze it you turn
it into a different vacuum state with
correlations
you're not getting around the heisenberg
uncertainty principle but you're
you're changing the the state variables
the
the the conjugate variables where the
where the uncertainty principle applies
and you're squeezing the uncertainty on
one of them you're putting all the noise
from the vacuum into something you don't
measure
because we're not measuring the vacuum
we're not interested in the vacuum we
put all the noise into one
one place and we measure
the the variable that has has had its
noise squeezed
so it's lower noise we measure that
variable
and we make sure that that variable is
containing the gravitational wave signal
because we're not interested in
in anything but the gravitational wave
signal we don't want to make a quantum
measurement
we want to get rid of the quantum noise
into one quadrature and in the other
quadrature have a very quiet
quantum quiet background so that's where
the gravitational wave signal is and
that's what a that's what's going on
with
with uh squeezed light um
the light comes in uh the vacuum
fluctuations are squeezed
so that uh um the they don't come back
out
in the interference pattern uh what
comes back out in the interference
pattern is much quieter
so does that work well in in geo 600
the black line this is one of the
sensitivity curves like the one i showed
you before the black line is what is
before squeezing
it happens only at high frequencies
where the shot noise dominates it
doesn't happen down here
where we have vibration noise but the
shot noise is dominant here
and here after we introduce squeezing
this is the
sensitivity to gravitational waves
so that we've reduced the noise in the
gravitational wave observation channel
here by a factor of perhaps two or
something like that we've the the most
we've got is factors of two and a half
or three i think
for um the the reduction
in noise and that's a very significant
thing if you can reduce your noise by a
factor of two
you haven't you have improved the reach
of your detector by a factor of two
you've improved the volume it surveys by
a factor of eight
so you have improved the number of you
you get ten times as many
gravitational wave sources by just
introducing squeezing by a factor two or
two and a half something like that
so that's a really significant
improvement in your
uh gravitational wave um uh detection
ability
and it's all done with with with the
deepest uh quantum mechanics totally
mysterious
this is what the apparatus really looks
like this is the geo
uh vacuum tanks for um the
interior mirrors and the power recycling
mirror and all of that stuff
but all this is the table that contains
the um um squeezed light uh apparatus
and so it's not a trivial job
to impose this uh squeezing on the
vacuum fluctuations
but that's what happens um i think i
should stop there
it's half past now and um i think i've
uh should have tried your patience the
one thing that maybe i'll show you one
more thing
i just want to show you something about
um uh
um the
uh um lisa
uh slimeshow
ah that's not what i wanted to do
ah this is a
and now i've lost
the slide i wanted here we are
that's it this is lisa pathfinder again
i just wanted to show you the pictures
of of the lisa
thing lisa um this is pathfinder
it's a big can with with two
test masses separated by half a meter
and uh so inside this is the diagram i
showed you earlier which
all that uh those free test masses that
are sitting there and the interferometry
would just happen along here we're just
trying to measure changes in distances
and so on over that very short baseline
the interfam this is the optical bench
the interferometry is very similar to
what we'll do with full lisa it's just
the separation isn't
isn't good um so um
uh it's not a gravitational wave
detector but a good test of
of the um uh of the principles of
the interferometry but otherwise it's
very similar the the least
interferometry
we don't have cavities we just send a
signal up and then and then come back
we're measuring return time
but because you can only focus a beam of
light narrowly you can but it still
still spreads out over a million
kilometers it spreads out
huge it's it's it's uh tens of
kilometers wide and
compared to the spacecraft that's
receiving it so there's a big reduction
in the amplitude of received light from
from the laser from once to the other
and we only have one watt lasers
um and uh so the light that's received
at one end is very
small if we just reflected it back with
a mirror we'd never get any photons back
at all
so it's transponded so we have we're
doing what the spacecraft people do
we have a receiving system that senses
the incoming light
and has an independent laser that's
slaved to the incoming light and sends
back with the right phase and so on so
it says
it's an active mirror it's an amplifying
mirror a transponder
um that's this that's one of the that's
the heart of the lisa
um uh technology and um
uh so so uh um
apart from that you get it's a it's a
two arm uh you know it's a
two pass one up and one down uh
apparatus it's the same
as the uh as the three term relation
only in a triangular array you can put
together any two of those
arms to to form an interference pattern
so we get three independent
gravitational wave signals
and they really are independent if the
gravitational waves are short wavelength
compared to the arms because they're
affecting
all the arms differently so we so we get
a lot more information about the
gravitational waves that way
but basically the technology is the
technology at least a pathfinder plus
this transponding
to get the the right intensity and
that's how lisa will work
okay so i think i should stop there and
we can take questions
yes
i still don't understand one thing you
said that wavelength is not important on
the
return time but when i see
interferometer i can't imagine
how wavelength may be not important so
could you just explain it uh you mean
the wavelength of the
of the light yes yeah um well i can do
white light interferometry if
if i'm really good um if i have an
interferometer
with exactly equal arms then every
wavelength
will come back and interfere with with
uh with
with itself in the right way and i'll
get a white light interferometer and it
doesn't matter what my wavelength is
so so the wavelength is not relevant and
inside this parameter we are measuring
the return time or
it's the the interferometer measures the
differences in return time so the light
goes out
comes back and if there's a change in
the
in the transmission time along one arm
relative to the other
then you get a slightly out of phase
signal
now the wavelength is important in terms
of how accurately you can measure it
but it's not important for the for the
effect of the gravitational wave and
printing on it
okay thanks
i'm talking now about an earthbound
construction
with uh pendulum suspension and so on uh
wouldn't
particularly if i um many times
between the mirrors wouldn't the
pressure of the photons
already move the mirrors yes yeah
so there's a balance we have to worry
about those things there's a balance
um that's one of those things that i
didn't talk about but it's very
is very important um there's uh
photon pressure uh with a lot of photons
on
on the mirrors is traded off against the
accuracy with which you can measure the
photon shot noise
um in our present regime we're limited
by shot noise but if we pump up the
laser power
to the final levels that we expect about
100 watts
or 200 watts laser input we will be in a
trade-off situation where we have to
worry about those things
yeah and then people have thought of
many there are many more optical tricks
that
people then think about to try to get
around these things and squeezing is one
of them
but um but yeah it's it's an important
thing
sorry there's a question right there
does this signal recycling
increase shot noise because less light
is going to detect
um uh
no so you mean less light is coming out
to the photodiode yeah
um um no because
um in the end uh because you have a
cavity
in the end you're getting quite you're
getting roughly the same amount of light
coming out
and the shot noise anyway is in the
interference pattern at the beam
splitter
it's not um it's the randomness of the
interference it's not the
the the photon counting at the
photodiode it's
it's all at what's happening at the beam
splitter
could you explain this concept of this
light
i mean to eliminate this vacuum noise a
little bit
once more um
so
in the standard description of light of
the electromagnetic fields
um you uh
you can construct a hamiltonian based on
um
the number of photons for example
and
the the
the the the uh the uncertainty principle
um i think it's right uh but i might
i might be oversimplifying here the
uncertainty principle there is an
uncertainty
between uh intensity and time or or or
the number of
of of counting and and and
the ability to measure um the time
arrival of things
and um uh and so if you pump up if you
have a
a lot of photons um uh then
then you uh improve your your
measurement of time
uh your the time arrival of anything
it's the phase isn't it yeah it's not
the time it's the phase yeah
that's right thank you um
but you don't have to have those as your
as your as your conjugate variables in
constructing
the description of the electromagnetic
field in the cavity
and you can
you can you can go over to a description
in which
the two conjugate variables are the are
the two outputs uh
from the beam splitter the the
constructive and destructive
interference basically intensities
um which are independent of each which
are independent of each other they
depend
and they're they're a function of this
phase shift that you get between the two
arms
so in principle you you could put all
the noise into the
all the quantum noise so having
constructed those two
then then it's a question of can you
find the technology
to uh change the heisenberg
uncertainty circle into an ellipse
in in such a way that the uh you reduce
the uncertainty
in the um in the intensity of light
that's coming out the
beam splitter to the to the detection
point and at the cost of increasing the
uncertainty
of the light that's going in the other
direction back to the power recycling
mirror
um so uh so you you're
trying to reshape the heisenberg
uncertainty ellipse in the new variables
uh and and so basically
you try to choose variables that
correspond to the two different
uh exit paths from the from the
interferometer
um how you do that i i'm at a loss to
describe myself
uh that's where all those mirrors in
that in that
thing are coming in but the principle is
to try to
try to make the part of the light that's
carrying your gravitational wave signal
as
as quiet as possible and as long as you
make that one of the conjugate variables
um then it's just a matter of how can i
make how can i reshape
the the the uncertainty ellipse
i don't get around the uncertainty i
just put more uncertainty in one
of the conjugate variables and less than
the other
perhaps a stupid question would it be a
good idea to put a really really long
light fiber inside satellite so
you know the total length will be very
large and there will be no noises from
earthquakes yeah
so
uh people have people have thought about
uh about that
one of the problems with um there are a
number of
of issues one is that the light in a
fiber doesn't go at the speed of light
so you have
you have a material problem but second
one is the fibers are
intrinsically imperfect um there's a lot
of scattering uh compared to what we can
do in a vacuum cavity
so the amount of light you can store is
is limited
plus there's a lot of thermal effects in
in these materials so even if you have
no external disturbances
you will get little popping and little
uh all sorts of little
thermal disturbances we see this with
the coatings on our mirrors
um we see uh when we when we turn up the
light intensity we see
lots of little glitches in our data that
that we think come from
thermal effects which which are not in
thermal equilibrium
you know they're little domains that may
release or or change or something
but in a fiber the way fibers are drawn
that that happens
um uh that happens a lot
so so um at the moment it's much better
to have just a vacuum cavity than
something actually
a material system actually containing
the light
but it's not a stupid question
the mirror is up on the moon which would
make
a really very long obviously one arm
instrument could that be used
um actually yeah the people who do laser
ranging to the moon have
have talked about setting limits on
gravitational waves in in that
particular frequency band
the the the problem is the reflecting
area
uh of those uh mirrors is very small so
so the um the light that you get back
is is they they can count the individual
photons
so uh you know photon
shot noise is very is the dominant noise
uh and uh so it that limits the
sensitivity a lot
if we put up huge huge mirrors on the
moon
then that would be something but then
you also have you know
the laser light traveling through the
atmosphere and all sorts of um
other noise things that are imprinted on
it
um but people have talked about using it
are there further questions okay
good thank you
it's wonderful that we had such a
masterful conclusion to the lectures
from our school thank you very much
so to me it's zero surprise that uh
students complemented your lectures a
lot already in the break
and i'm sure they will remember the
school for a very long time and your
lectures
and this is for you to remember the
lectures for the lifetime of this cup
right thank you very much and we also
have and it's
a happy coincidence that your german is
so good so this is
actually a kepler's astronomia nova with
lots of comments and so on and also
very very highly recommended book oh
wonderful
thank you very much